he hadn't no end welcome to this video
this is about and I wanted to say around
again I'm Game seven of the World
Championship match and um yeah the
length of the video which I don't know
quite yet how long it will be but it'll
be short relatively short points you
towards the result already yeah probably
not spoiling people all that much
because everybody kind of probably will
follow quite closely and while the games
are live anyway so let's get that get
this going and see what game seven is
all about yeah panicking when t fords a
second kayaking white game in a row and
you went d4 so that's new he played in
four in order all the games of the first
half of the match and got no way up here
those Spanish willow pass with the d3
and a 3 and so on they didn't didn't get
him anywhere didn't have a single game
but even the slightest opening advantage
yeah Saudi for now and cousin goes d5
and place the Slav that was not probably
the most expected reply I mean not that
that's not played by him he has the
sloth in his repertoire as as he has
many openings so let's say to play this
occasionally but usually cause a defense
with the with an Enzo one in this case
he is playing like the Queen's in yet
and the Queens gambit declined mostly
the Queens gambit declined in this move
water so this would be the more expected
choice but it is a sloth it went like
this socal a key places only Knight c3
and III line in those different openings
many things depend on move order and
this is also one of those cases watch
here has basic claim yeah 3 3 ways to
play the same you can put the two nights
out
I can't ear and don't bother about the
sea for porn so black hair could
actually take this the main line
classical Slav while you can play with
III at some point like yes in the game
or you can also play you three in this
move order the difference between having
the night here and the knight on c3 is
that in starting ended here black
actually is able to play Bishop f5 right
away and usually this position or this
line is assessed as being very very
marginally more comfortable for white as
white quite often we get the bishop pair
but black is extremely sounded solid of
course it's not the only choice like a
nautical a 60 g six things like that the
difference in with what kayaking
Bellator's they're here Bishop f5 is not
as attractive as it is with the 1983
because YTM has this option and here
black basically has the choice between
putting up some kind of passive defense
by actually going back or play a move
like yeah when the Queen B 6 is actually
blundering a pawn right you have to do
something passive him on the alternative
would be them somewhat surprising pawn
sacrifice here which is playable for
black but probably on them on the
slightly dodgy side man so this is what
a black has to put up with him he cannot
so easily play Bishop f5 accountant
place to move a six this is a branch of
the chip an ankle Slav the a6 love and
this is actually one of the more popular
most you this is a good waiting move why
should commit in some way here and now
the most popular to move probably for
why this Knight f3 and here black mm SL
choice can go eat six Bishop f5 and so
on this is the most common move a
success played for 42
reasons like once they have b5 available
in some cases and it sounds funny but
that's also the idea okay seven in some
cases when white plays Queen to be three
for example um if you imagine a
situation like that your black actually
goes through a seven and covers the deep
on this is not bad at all for black and
I can you can click the move for a
Bishop d3 and here we see an additional
idea of a six actually just not two
ideas but maybe like three or four and
so there should be three what is cards
doing now he has a choice but the line
that is believed to be best for black
and this is like the common that the
consensus for years when I started to
play the a6 laughs that was in the in
the mid-2000s if that's the correct
expression like 2006-2007 maybe a little
bit early evening I paid earlier 2004-5
and so on like 10 years ago even back
then this was believed to be the best
reply and this is what cars in plates
also today so that was my choice in
games it's not nothing nothing new let's
say yeah Knight f3 played back a hockey
and c5 played by Carlton now we get into
a position that can actually arise via
various move orders okay besides the one
here in the game there are a couple of
other moves orders that could be could
lead to this position one popular one
from the Queens gambit accepted leading
to this position same position as in the
game what alternatively there is this
Vienna line here of the Queens gambit
declined where exactly the same position
can
rise so it's an interesting effect that
you can get the same position from tons
of what is not however yet debated is
that this is entirely harmless for black
it always was rendered totally harmless
however there has been recently or one
or two games where this was tried and we
will see a little bit later i will show
you an example so white castle b5 the
reason why this is usually believed to
be harmless black is that the knight on
c3 is not perfectly placed usually with
why do you want more flexibility about
the night for example d2 can be a square
in some cases or simply you don't want
to worry about before hitting your piece
so we should be to play this looks very
modest but this actually is probably the
best tribe there should be seven and now
ki can play the not very exciting
looking move we have to have to admit
that d takes you five him and this way
of handling the position with this
simplification because we we see that
queens are probably come off this
actually has some bite and what I want
to show you is the moves of a game that
was played a little bit earlier this
year um the 22 Chinese top players run
you a and one-half and he actually won
how got into some trouble with black we
should look at this because it also
demonstrates a very nice strategy for
white this all looks pretty harmless but
white now has a plan in mind or here in
this case what's wrong here hello plan
in mind which is very typical and and
and nice to see him very instructive 922
what's the point here and they will see
what happens maybe we should be
but I'm sorry 93 96 and now every
castles and e4 and if white and actually
I think probably one how could have done
something a little bit different earlier
but I don't want to analyze this game
all that much this sub or this is this
really a game of this line but I want to
show the structure this is a very good
setup for wide against this kind of en
català bishop yeah the bishop here is
pretty useless and white has key ideas
that he can put the bishop here can use
maybe the weekend to see five square or
you can play a four in the right moment
to try to break up the screen site
information this is actually a fairly
uncomfortable position for black already
not like he's losing man but it's
there's some pressure already here and
this is probably one of the key ideas
that one wants to go go for him but
Carlton didn't take he what my voice was
all find the whole day but now probably
the the area is a little bit too dry
from the heating so txt five and console
now pretty much played instantly the
move Knight to c6 that is the an
interesting idea what he wants to do is
basically avoid this scenario here by
getting a better version of this
structure with open DNC farm so he wants
to take care later and don't actually
give wiped some kind of temporal
checking on d1 also note that if you
just recapture clock you have to move
the king which is also not particularly
ideal in general in this kind of
situation with the open DNC file black
usually does not like to have the pawn
cm you would rather prefer them back on
b7 the people
for example yeah okay 96 and now this is
already a critical position now of the
game and kayaking took a moment there I
wanted to check out 10 minutes I want to
show how much it exactly was the you
took 10 minutes and then play a move
that that really made me do like oh yeah
simply because I mean if you play like
that how are you ever going to win a
game we will see and the only really
interesting option here for wide is the
following which I understand is maybe
not easy to see to find on whatever but
I mean there's there's something called
whole trap and I mean I don't really
know what they were looking at but if
you are constantly surprised by by a
normal-looking moves on move eight or
nine or ten anyway so this is the
interesting interesting line that the
engines point out it may mean it's also
something that you can find over the
board like a four is the only principled
way of handling this and now have to be
for the move 95s also not total rocket
science because you can pretty easily
see that if black takes it then black
cannot keep this piece and once this
becomes clear this becomes a very
interesting line I mean so just so just
to show how force it is rock the eight a
form a white and black has no choice
here if you take that this is looking
bad so before has to be played actually
and now this funny moving I'd be five
yeah he'll black also has to take the
night the capture on c5 it's not going
to be all that charade because of the
check and yeah white is just taking this
pawn and black does not have enough for
that I mean he can try this move try to
trap the night but 94 I would reply and
that makes it dumb awkward for black why
definitely is better in this
so the only thing that black really can
do is here to take it why ticks and now
this night cannot be saved if you move
the night away then c6 is going to be
very very awful in position like that I
mean black probably has to give it back
and then 95 leads to big issues you
don't really have a good move here and
this is a plaster or you play here and
white eggs and this is actually a
flat-out winning because Luke d1 and
Luke a7 will basically win that piece
it's it's pretty much impossible to save
it it's a terribly bad position so this
all boils down to one line a black has
to take the same pics takes and here
white is a little bit better I mean it's
not fantastic but if anybody why it is a
little bit better because of that
slightly weakened be for porn I've had
that was kind of positions in some line
in the semi slob and my experience is
really that this is all so easy for
black to play and you run zero risk as
well it's a very one-sided affair so
this is probably what them kayaking
should have gone form here possibly 94
that's suggested by the engines this
move is probably not leading to that
much it looks good at first but there is
no clear continuation as this is covered
I mean it anybody widest slightly better
maybe he was a I know a little bit
surprised or shocked that Calvin was
playing this in like five seconds that
look while he knows that but okay this
is kind of to be expected um anyway what
he came up with is so unambitious that I
really don't know what to say with this
move not to d2 I mean a similar idea was
seen with the Queen trade but this is an
entirely different position simply yeah
Magnus took the pawn on c5 and now 94
yeah okay we want to drain stuff and
in this position you really don't need
to look at it all that much to see that
if anybody is better here must be black
I mean black is better developed em the
bishop won't see one is not doing
anything I mean he addresses that
quickly III but I'm not saying that why
this position is it's like super
terrible here but what kind of opening
result is that I mean if anybody black
is better and he's kind of such an easy
game here yeah night before played by
Colin looks normal attacking attacking
the knight and the bishop f3 is pretty
much the only move when you do you have
no square to go to with us tonight and
yeah here that's an interesting moment
and a somewhat surprising movement
because cards now didn't take all that
long and castles like a minute or so and
you have to move at five and I think
it's a bit strange that he did not look
at this a little bit more because i feel
this should be the way to try to punish
wide for his passive play it probably
won't lead to a win I mean and but it
looks like black is pressing a little
bit there um white after a 5k he cannot
play the check that that is not an
answer basically exposes to pieces so
what should why do he has 96 check or
you can move the night like 2d to water
g5 if you have the check and a black is
going to take it takes and now you can
take a chemical 7 that was the line that
I looked at this is not the only line
but it's fairly sensible yet here black
is so it's a little bit better if he
moves the bishop here white player we're
going to snatch upon and a3 is
alternative after which Bishop f6 would
be 1 p-7 a B and now move like a second
to f7
and it's a little bit better for black
you know this pawn structure is a bit
vulnerable and we have the more active
pc of the bishop on f6 so it's not like
winning but black definitely is calling
the shots here so this is one line and
the other line which is probably a
better version for wine is to play the
night here on 2d tool in both case
however black is also a bit more
comfortable he will take him night inks
and after the trade you should have six
with the tempo yeah so why probably
doesn't want to sacrifice stuff yet so
not deform to block the bishop and now
some normal move on to what Desmond
notes a king f7 a king f7 or the aid is
probably also fine yeah but probably
probably connecting books make sense
yeah and again black is a bit more
active in this position a bishop on f6
is a bit more active it's quite a bit
more space it is probably not going to
be a huge but it's better for black
quite quite clearly better not clearly
better i mean it is clear that black is
better but just a little bit but it's so
discussion that he has a slightly more
comfortable position but counter
clicking castle which is a bit strange i
think bishop a three and now on yeah
that it's a puzzling move now because
yeah black is definitely fine and maybe
is still a little bit more comfortable
with a move like Bishop to g5 and the
bishop is unprotected down and carson
simply ignored this this fact and
playgroups eh that's really puzzling
because the Lions then now come up the
board are I mean they are not difficult
at all and it's a bit mysterious what
exactly he missed especially from a
position which was very comfortable for
him yeah so what's the problem wife has
this check yeah this is discovered
attack
not exactly rocket science and the lines
now have had it clear the black has to
change of course Bishop d7 yeah and now
there are all kinds of things hanging
this this night is hanging the rook is
hanging and indirectly f8 so a black um
uh now had to calculate a couple of
lines and what it's pretty clear once
you look at all the lines that in
everything black will be a little bit
worse a little bit it's just the
question what kind of position to take I
will show you a line that looks very
logical and it's was rejected by carlson
and we see from why root p8 program that
looks completely normal but here I am
Bishop before Bishop takes him you
should have eight and have a
simplification a huge simplification but
what we should not underestimate that in
a position like this black actually has
to be somewhat precise it's not so easy
here yeah Roxy one potentially whoopsie
six this is not completely equal blood
will suffer a little bit him yeah we
know these kind of situations from the
Catalan black has to always worry about
this pawn cousin played a different
print in a different way and I think in
a better way he took on a one-year first
we should be four and Bishop f6 yeah in
here White has a choice now we can play
as he did in the game winning a pawn on
I mean this is probably the better
choice or you can play like this Bishop
c8 is this this looks kind of similar
but here black actually is ready to
invade there is no media on the
also so if white now plays that say is
indeed upon move like is always ready to
do this and rook g6 doesn't work due to
Bishop e7 so here there is no problem
with the route coming on the six rank
and compared to the line that we had
earlier so this is just completely equal
so ki can decided instead to take this
route and after this this and rook takes
this pawn is lost yeah and it was taken
so Carden is actually giving up a pawn
he did not need to give up a pawn he had
this other position that i showed before
where he was suffering and inset you
prefer to do that and i think it is the
better choice if we look at this here
black is a pawn down but it is up to
opposite colored bishops and it is very
very unlikely that this pawn is ever
going to advance here to a4 as black can
always take it on pass on the opposite
colored bishops him give black enormous
drawing chances drawing potential any
hook trade for example would be an
immediate draw as wife can really
absolutely absolutely nothing with the
spawn I was actually surprised when I
was watching the broadcast when it shows
different opinions and maybe a limited
understanding on my part then civilian
gustafson on the chest 24 commentary
actually gave white like two out of ten
winning chances i think this is just
totally dead but probably my problem i
would give give me zero winning shots
here with white if my opponent is not
dropping dead because you actually
cannot do all that much in terms of i
mean how is black going to lose that
position besides falling asleep or
knowing something really stupid i don't
i don't see it and in the game nothing
happened with him there was one moment
however which we have to point out and
this is really a also a little bit
puzzling and this is right here ya
having up to this point i think all this
was fairly am
logical looking and here the next move
Batman Hawking is a bit puzzling because
he played the move g4g form which was
answered by G hive and and this actually
means the structure now that white can
never with any I mean it can never play
for so I'm trying to say as black is
very happy to destroy the structure now
there's something like that there's a
total blockade white can never put the
pawns forward and this would basically
end all ambitions so this is strange
though that he played this G formal
instead fo definitely would have
continued this game and while I still
believe that a black should not lose and
I mean it goes on it definitely goes on
here if I've is a serious idea and get
black will go here probably know he in
this position actually 84 is possible
yeah this is a trick voice I'm sorry I
you can go here right here this is
possible because the bishop is this is
what i meant with blundering stuff yeah
this is something you should avoid your
wife gets a dangerous a pawn so black
probably should go here any five and
this is still I mean it goes on it goes
on and the drawing potential that black
has is very very high but it is a game
that will definitely continue and the
bishop stays outside of the chain would
always cover this pawn to be very
difficult to move the airport so I still
think that it's extremely likely to end
in a draw but it continues and after
year why he has actually no way forward
and actually here they already agreed to
a draw so I wasn't surprised that this
now was it redrawn I mean maybe from a
match a strategy perspective it was
surprising but
the position itself I believe he is
actually completely dead if white would
go 45 as we seen earlier warning g4 this
is at least something you can try so
that is a seventh draw in a row and a
little bit of a strange game yeah the
opening playback kayaking was again very
a yeah to put it in a positive way
modest and cars and Indra Liam yeah it
was a bit strange why not think about f5
a little bit end and and I mean why
cancelled so quickly it was a bit bit
surprising and then he really this is
this luke c8 is pretty little this is a
bit of a blunder actually really because
from a completely comfortable position a
black gets into something that is
annoying deeply annoying to to have to
play from a position of strength
actually yeah so what do we have overall
we have seven games played and we've got
five games left we now can count it the
other way so five games left not much
three games with accounts and having
wide I still think he's the favorite to
to to win the match but I mean we're
down to just a couple of games just five
and it proves to be difficult to beat
kayaking or visiting anything probably
it said would be karsland with why
because kayaking with widely place rock
like he doesn't even try to do stuff and
seems to be content with was with that
nothing and make it draw which is
straight is a strange strategy um but I
mean move like oopsy a maybe it pays off
and that he can that he plays and in a
way that cars and fields and can do
whatever and this is really not the case
yeah moves like rook c8 I mean he
probably ever looked something pretty
drastic with this move and sometimes
it's just luck that you that you
overlooked something and it's actually
not not killing you and it could could
have been
when maybe worse yeah anyway I hope you
enjoyed the coverage of this game game
eight will be played on Monday the 24th
so we're going to 21st and hope we'll
see a bit more excitement in that game
thanks for watching